[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight if you've been paying
attention lately you may have noticed
that President Trump doesn't like the
media and the media fervently don't like
him back it is a hate hate relationship
and it seems to be getting more
contentious by the day consider CNN's
headline just this morning so the
president you saw yesterday got a
strikingly positive health evaluation
here was CNN's take on it quote
overweight and doesn't exercise in other
words doctors say he's fine CNN calls
him fat this has been going on since the
very beginning except for the day that
he loved cruise missiles into Syria
which delighted official Washington as
it always does virtually all of trumps
press coverage has been negative
reporters don't simply disagree with the
administration on policy though they do
they feel personal contempt and loathing
for the president and their bosses have
encouraged them to express it in return
the president has struck back dismissing
the media as fake news in many cases
he's been right and others he's just
attacked news he doesn't like just like
all politicians do know under normal
circumstances part of the remedy for
this would be a responsible media
establishment reporters would raise
their standards and run fewer false
stories but these are not normal
circumstances suddenly there's a massive
and eager audience for conspiracy
theories and that is exactly why they're
going 24/7 with this Russian nonsense on
some of the other networks it is very
lucrative for them but there's another
reason to in the America of 2018
victimhood is power instead of improving
their journalism it's easier for
reporters to complain about how their
voices are somehow being suppressed the
irony of course is that free expression
really is under attack in this country
at the moment but most journalists don't
seem to care or even notice it heterodox
views are shattered off campus and often
threatened with violence twitter
routinely bans accounts for expressing
viewpoints its executives oppose Google
tampers with its search results secretly
to hide ideas it doesn't like and then
fires employees who express those ideas
and yet weirdly the media applaud all of
this they're not defenders of free
expression
guardians of Orthodoxy elite orthodoxy
today Republican Senator Jeff Flake of
Arizona took their side in his speech on
the Senate floor flake compared Trump's
criticism of the media to the Soviet
dictator Joseph Stalin one of history's
most prolific mass murderers because of
course barking at Jim Acosta during a
press conference is a lot like building
death camps or staging a famine in
Ukraine no one ever accused Jeff Flake
of being a genius though he is right on
one point government often is the
opponent of free expression remember for
example when President Obama kicked
newspaper reporters off his campaign
plane because their coverage of him
wasn't favorable enough you don't
remember that what actually happened
then there was the time the Obama
administration threatened to ban Fox
from the White House press corps because
we didn't suck up hard enough with the
time the Obama administration subpoenaed
the phone records from The Associated
Press or the time they named Fox News
reporter James Rosen in a criminal
complaint back in 2010 President Obama
actually described this news
organization Fox as quote destructive
for the long-term growth of a country
that has a vibrant middle class in other
words Fox News causes poverty now these
attacks on press freedom are on for
years where was Jeff Flake then we don't
remember him comparing Barack Obama to
Joseph Stalin or even bothering to
defend us Jeff Lee didn't hate Obama the
way he hates Donald Trump because Obama
didn't threaten the comfortable little
sign of cure that flake had carved out
for himself for so long if you're Jeff
Flake or Lindsey Graham or a dozen dozen
other Republican senators who secretly
despised their own voters the Obama
years were a perfect time for you you
could complain about Democratic control
of government in a low-grade way play
the role of a principled opposition give
a few floor speeches do a few TV hits
and then go home you didn't actually
have to do anything or change anything
it was the political equivalent of a
no-show job it was nice work if you
could get it there's a reason
Republicans haven't delivered a single
major conservative law since welfare
reform and that was more than 20 years
ago
no wonder guys like Jeff Flake loathe
Trump he called their bluff
suddenly Republicans have all the power
for the first time in decades that could
actually do what voters have
consistently asked them to do for years
secure the borders this time for real
slow the flood of immigration that is
making America poorer
more crowded and dangerously unstable
but they don't want to do that mostly
because their donors don't want them to
do that they can't admit that of course
so they call Trump Stalin suddenly it
all makes sense John Daniel Davidson is
a senior correspondent at the Federalist
and he joins us tonight John thanks
coming up thanks for having me so Trump
hates reporters I can certainly see why
reporters don't like that I don't always
like his criticisms criticisms of the
press they strike me though as less
dangerous as an actual Stalinist dynamic
where the press sucks up to people in
power and I'm struck by how common that
was for the eight years preceding this
administration and no one ever said
anything about it why well you're
absolutely right you had reporters from
mainstream outlets routinely take
private meetings with President Obama
and be fed stories and narratives as the
Obama administration liked to say and
then come back and regurgitate them
point by point in support of whatever
Obama administration policy was being
sold to them that day this was the this
was the standard operating procedure for
major news outlets for eight years and
now they have the Trump administration
which offends them and their
sensibilities and they're offended by
the policies that the Trump
administration is trying to push and so
they engage in this sort of hysterical
overblown criticism that we saw Jeff
Flake kind of join in on today on the
Senate floor I mean Jeff Flake is a
mediocrity but I'm in an irrelevant and
it's retiring but I'm interested more in
the reporters who really do shape our
understanding of what's going on in the
world it seems weird to me that they're
ignoring the actual crisis in free
expression which is real so I've been in
the workforce 26 years there's never
been a time in my lifetime where more
people were fired more quickly for
expressing their opinions in the
workplace this is an epidemic I don't
ever see coverage of that why well like
you said before the press chooses not to
see that because all the people who are
getting fired have the wrong views you
know you look back to the firing of
Brendan Eich at Mozilla
it's kind of yes canary in the coalmine
you know that seemed like a long time
ago but that was a harbinger of things
to come that are very widespread with
organizations like Facebook and Twitter
that are essentially media organizations
now that function like media
organization yes that have these
draconian policies where they're
obviously censoring views that they
don't like they're obviously don't
really care about free expression you
saw these undercover videos of Twitter
executives saying oh yeah we cooperate
with the Chinese government in expelling
and banning people from Twitter all the
time
they're not really interested in free
expression and it's troubling to see
just how disinterested they are and
uninterested they are in the issue at
all but they're the Guardians they're
the opposite of what they ought to be
they're the guardians of Orthodoxy
rather than the defenders of heterodoxy
of a journalist should instinctively
take the side of the one guy who stands
up with a different opinion you saw
James do more at Google get fired for it
Aprilia nine personal email or memo
about diversity and you saw the whole
staff of business insider practically
piled on and said I'm glad he's gone
he's a threat to the Republic what
happened who are these people posing as
journalists well you know the one thing
Jeff Flake gets wrong and the mainstream
media gets wrong is that the number one
you know threat if there's a if there's
a main threat to our democracy when it
comes to the media it's that the media
has totally thrown away its credibility
with the American people
there was this Gallup poll out that
showed more Americans have a negative
view of the media than have a positive
view of the media that's not good for a
democracy we need to have a robust
credible media to hold power accountable
and to inform the citizenry it don't
have that right now because because the
media does not see itself as the you
know guardians of free speech the
guardians of common Americans holding
power accountable they see themselves as
you know as you say protectors of the
status quo that's if they were half as
skeptical at big business as they are of
Donald Trump we'd be a lot safer I would
be a lot happier John thank you thank
you